Et si tout était là,
y compris des composants organiques,
la vie avait peut-être vu le jour.
Curiosity a aussi foré dans cette terre rouge
et a soulevé d'autres matières.
Et on était très enthousiastes quand on a vu ça.
Parce que ce n'était pas la Mars rouge,
c'était une matière grise ;
c'est la Mars grise.
On l'a emmenée sur le rover,
on l'a goûtée,
et devinez quoi ?
On a goûté des composants organiques --
du carbone, de l’hydrogène, de l'oxygène,
du nitrogène, du phosphore, du soufre --
ils étaient tous là.
Alors Mars dans son passé,
avec beaucoup d'eau,
peut-être beaucoup de temps,
aurait pu avoir de la vie,
aurait pu avoir cette étincelle,
aurait pu croître.
Et cette vie est-elle toujours là ?
On ne le sait pas.
Mais il y a quelques années
on a commencé à observer quelques cratères.
Pendant l'été,
des lignes sombres apparaissaient sur les côtés de ces cratères.
Plus nous regardions,
plus nous observions de cratères,
plus nous voyions de traits.
On en connait désormais plus d'une douzaine.
Il y a quelques mois le conte de fées s'est réalisé.
Nous avons annoncé au monde que nous savions ce qu'étaient ces traces.
C'est de l'eau liquide.
Ces cratères pleurent pendant l'été.
De l'eau liquide coule dans ces cratères.
Alors que va-t-on faire maintenant --
maintenant qu'on voit l'eau ?
Eh bien, ça nous dit que Mars a tous les ingrédients nécessaires à la vie.
Dans son passé, elle avait peut-être les deux tiers de son hémisphère nord
recouverts par un océan.
Elle a de l'eau qui coule maintenant.
De l'eau liquide sur sa surface.
Elle a des composants organiques.
Elle a toutes les bonnes conditions.
Alors que va-t-on faire ensuite ?
On va lancer une série de missions
pour commencer cette quête de vie sur Mars.
Et maintenant c'est plus attirant que jamais.
Alors qu'on sort du système solaire,
voici la petite lune Encelade.
Ce n'est pas ce qu'on appelle traditionnellement la zone habitable,
cet endroit autour du soleil.
C'est beaucoup plus loin.
Cet objet devrait être de la glace sur un noyau de silicate.
Mais qu'a-t-on trouvé ?
Cassini était là depuis 2006,
et après quelques années a regardé derrière elle en quittant Encelade
et nous a tous surpris.
Encelade tire des panaches d'eau dans le système solaire
qui retombent sur la lune.
Quel environnement fabuleux.
Cassini il y a quelques mois a aussi volé dans le panache,
et a mesuré les particules de silicate.
D'où vient la silice ?
Elle doit venir du lit de l'océan.
L'énergie de marée est générée par Saturne,
tirant et serrant cette lune --
faisant fondre cette glace,
créant un océan.
Mais elle agit aussi sur le noyau.
Alors, la seule chose sur Terre nous venant à l'esprit et
qui fait quelque chose de similaire :
les monts hydrothermaux.
Dans les profondeurs des océans, les monts hydrothermaux ont été découverts en 1977.
Les océanographes ont été totalement surpris.
Et maintenant il y en a des milliers sous l'océan.
Qu'y trouve-t-on ?
Les océanographes, quand ils vont regarder ces monts hydrothermaux,
les voient grouiller de vie,
quand bien même l'eau est acide ou alcaline --
ce n'est pas grave.
Alors les monts hydrothermaux
sont une demeure fabuleuse pour la vie ici sur Terre.
Alors qu'en est-il d'Encelade ?
Nous croyons que, puisqu'elle a de l'eau,
et ce depuis longtemps,
et que nous croyons qu'elle a des monts hydrothermaux,
avec peut-être les bons composants organiques,
c'est un lieu où la vie pourrait exister.
Et pas seulement microbienne --
peut-être plus complexe puisqu'elle a eu le temps d'évoluer.
Une autre lune, très similaire,
est Europe.
Galileo a visité le système de Jupiter en 1996
et a fait de fabuleuses prises de vue d'Europe.
Europe, comme on le sait, a un océan sous la croûte de glace.
La mission de Galileo nous l'a dit, mais on n'a jamais vu de panaches.
Mais on ne les avait pas cherchés.
Hubble,
il y a seulement quelques années,
observant Europe,
a vu des panaches d'eau
jaillissants des crevasses dans l'hémisphère sud,
exactement comme Encelade.
Ces lunes,
qui ne sont pas dans ce qu'on appelle traditionnellement une zone habitable,
qui sont dans le système solaire,
ont de l'eau liquide.
Et s'il y a des composants organiques,
il y a peut-être de la vie.
C'est un ensemble fabuleux de découvertes
parce que ces lunes ont été dans cet environnement comme ça
depuis des milliards d'années.
La vie a commencé ici sur Terre, on croit, après environ les premiers 500 millions,
et regardez où on est.
Ces lunes sont des lunes fabuleuses.
Une autre lune qu'on regarde est Titan.
Titan est une énorme lune de Saturne.
Elle est peut-être beaucoup plus grande que la planète Mercure.
Elle a une vaste atmosphère.
Elle est tellement vaste --
et c'est principalement de l'azote avec un peu de méthane et d'éthane --
que vous devez la regarder à travers un radar.
Et sur la surface, Cassini a trouvé du liquide.
On voit des lacs...
en fait presque la taille de notre Mer Noire à certains endroits.
Et cette zone n'est pas de l'eau liquide ;
c'est du méthane.
S'il y a un endroit dans le système solaire où la vie n'est pas comme nous,
où le remplaçant de l'eau est un autre solvant --
et ça pourrait être du méthane --
ça pourrait être Titan.
Y a-t-il de la vie au-delà de la Terre dans le système solaire ?
Nous ne le savons pas encore,
mais nous cherchons sans relâche.
Les données qu'on reçoit sont palpitantes
et nous disent --
nous forcent à voir les choses de nouvelles manières.
Je crois qu'on est sur la bonne voie.
Que dans les 10 ans à venir, on répondra à cette question.
Et si on y répond,
et si la réponse est positive,
alors la vie est partout dans le système solaire.
Pensez-y.
Nous ne sommes peut-être pas seuls.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)